what are you I got the lion I think you
are the unicorn right yeah you're the
unit one so that is the fish the
scorpion and what the bloody hell is
that
Oh water from a big jug
thank you God you know kinda dalian it
just heals myself why did you have to go
do that probably do need to look around
in this room there
cool one more to go um now where do we
go
are you okay oh no not you mr. white you
can sneak past look as if you move
slowly says Sergio thank you that is
useful that is helpful
I don't get them I think okay okay so
apparently what do I need to do don't
know
that's a like get past if they wants you
again guess so it's my last a little bit
easier you know I don't know then tickle
my head tickle my head give me a head
scratch - any survivors consider this a
gift for anyone still alive or still
unfortunate enough to be alive
keep your eyes peeled for those could be
[ __ ] that look like they were skinned
alive lickers we call them they're blind
as bats
oh you're right the hearing more than
makes up for that so long as you don't
run around like a total idiot that's
what this is why I do guns are blazing
you should be able to sit right by them
probably either way make like my grandma
and creep around as slow as possible
random yeah anyway not that I want to go
the cheeky calls that and I've got a
friend to revenge
all right David thanks appreciate that
still have not managed to find myself a
key tonight
dude just chill out would you stay dead
damnit okay [ __ ] this
oh good at least I had the sense to do
that oh bloody out oh my god
that is so cool that you could just take
that grenade in his frickin mouth and
then it flashed us everyone does fun
whoo here we go and now we put this
battery here nice progressing guys we
are love a room cat it would be nice if
I could just get like some [ __ ] ammo
though you know that would be really
splendid I would be extremely happy I
mean nah I would be extremely happy if I
could get the key card actually
right here we go
good kicks let go quick deck Cabo
oh my gosh I don't have anything
lady arrows snakes lady our snake I
think it's an era like thank you for my
medallion something more in here like no
I guess now you're gonna have first fun
[Music]
I know I must mr. brown but screw it
dawn is it still behind me I think it
actually is oh no it stayed up there
nothing oh that was spooky
oh thank gosh we're okay we're safe
I agree drained all the liquids are
terrifying hold in there buddy hold in
there hold on there nice but hold on I
still don't half the bloody shotgun
I don't want to go guys what am i done
wherever is this key card why can't I
find it no but all that is over this
side is that one hallway that we that is
blocked by the helicopter then you find
a handle for the Jag user stuff
cuz all this weight oh my god
what's this not weight huh well thank
you I thought this was where the bloody
thingies we're okay I was always running
past this dope we dope dope right yes
finally I'm so glad I didn't just carry
on going the Ruby that captivated Edward
the Black Prince the pearl that the
Queen of the Nile my milked dry the
diamond that led a queen to guillotine
there is no end the number of tails
related to the appeal of jewels this
mysterious red stone is simply the
latest to Sparkle amongst them like
those other jewels
this one's origin is unknown it's said
that it once adorns a noble woman's job
box and was even dedicated to a wise
King this fall this stone that's long
been shrouded in legend will be on
display during auction there are sure to
be many eager enthusiasts there but dear
reader one would do well to approach
with care for devilry lies and beauty's
shadows this jaw has turned caring
Nobles who love their subjects into
disciplines despots more terrible than
Khaled Khaled gula and we have the tales
to prove it seriously it's precisely
because the jewels are bathed in blood
that their luster
has something in their hearts of people
everywhere okay
oh oh whoa whoa whoa oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa
I need to book I need to book okay wait
hold up I'll come back I need the book
so I've got the book now so I'm gonna
put in this guy's hand and see what
happens
he's happy because this goddess sky
let's look back he's a happy guy oh this
is the module I gotta sit
why why why should I have a scepter it's
like I I solve a puzzle and then I'm
confused because I'm like uh-huh nice a
pricey looking gemstone
okay
who fancies getting a shotgun I do
good let's go get one yummy why Leon do
not become a zombie after bite I think
he's immune isn't he
I'm obviously not a resident evil
connoisseur oh my god
why am i back here again what am i doing
what is my life there are reasons
oh yeah sugar oh my oh Jesus just run
Leon Leon Leon you got this you got this
muffin okay sorry restored oh yeah let
me got this
can I not just take out this one
yes yes yes yes thank you for all of
your help all of your help okay now it's
time to go
so it goes underground
that's it that's our way out lieutenant
Brennan Marvin it's time to go we need
to get you go hospital right now no no
save yourself
one have done so
look we can still make it out of here
together just
it's too late
you tried the I but I could stop it
we can't let this thing spray
it's on you now
just go
I understand
I won't let you down Marvin okay
right so to get back when use we need to
handle okay
no elevated music that's sad
Corrigan see themselves too seriously
how it is I'll let you know the Bob will
have escaped
[Music]
you to put a little pick or Keith miss
like me
I got to gonna need
okay that's not welcoming
yeah
Tom subbies such an attention [ __ ] and
plea oh my god
I don't want that item yeah
indeed let's go our bulls okay how am I
gonna do this okay I got a grenade I go
up oh nice yeah that's kit but it's a
dead end those hope I'm not that great
dude what the hell he wasn't getting his
frickin gun out what's wrong with him I
don't think he wants to he's ignoring me
okay
right the the I the I the I am sir
sigh
get them in the eye get him in the eye
oh come on oh come on oh come on he's an
angry angry do
I need to get them in the eye can you
face the other way I need to get you at
a different angle please open your eye
not that one
Oh God he's asked me to help him that's
super-creepy
did I pick up and I just picked up all
good
nice
thank you
very much enjoy it
oh my god what's up with you I think I
think that was my bike prime time oh
yeah
although I do feel slightly bad because
it was he was asking me to help him
[Applause]
okay hope we go
Wow
perfect
where's this even do why am I putting
this event oh okay
yes ah
I feel good that I'm finding all these
hip pouches Leon the most handsome boy
no Homer
[Music]
sounds like werewolves did you hear that
some wearables yeah
no you know tide damn need a keycard
who was that
stay sharp
FBI
sorry
thank you your help
surprised you made it
di huh rookie what's going on here sorry
that information is classified
are you going do yourself a favor
stop asking questions and get the hell
out
well if she's a sassy one hey I'm not
done talking to you good you think that
butters right yes look oh there's a lot
of green doors
this is not look friendly let's turn
around I know we should probably follow
her I want to find some ammo or
something
thank you hmm what's this ah nice
peaceful
apparently in the demo someone found
that they've reused newspaper from
Resident Evil 7 which ironically is set
way in the future from this game point
so like it just did not make any sense
to be in the game I wonder if they've
changed that yeah you did it wasted
are these all Lots there's probably a
switch or something that I can use to
unlock the sounds so I'm guessing if I
tacked tact
philia take you out now you'll be less
nuisance to me in yeah here we go in the
future but so let's do that now
let's kill every zombie what that Leon
why why are you so surprised you've seen
this a thousand times now Annie's behind
bars
hello human you've been here long enough
she came in with a lie no no there's a
few of us oh that's good news I guess
yeah that's of course I am sent irons
union chief irons is he still around
who cares hopefully he's somebody's
dinner by now what do you mean by that
it's the bastard that locked me in here
I'm sure he had a good reason he did
how's about to blow the whistle on its
dirty ass oh no no I thought this was
the Loon who are blew everyone up I'm a
good deal good luck you sell enough
tickets there's no other way out of that
parking garage believe me sorry I can't
do that I have to talk to the chief what
what let him out you wanna punish what
what's coming I wanted him to be my
friend oh my gosh thing oh it's just me
why are you walking around some
nonchalant
wouldn't want to end up like betting
with you know him it was an informant
had information views to my
investigation so what he said was true
hmm hey you can't keep walking away from
me I don't even know your name I'm in
the on Kennedy and I'm scared so please
stay with me cuz you seem like nasty
girl before it's too late and the top
names Ava
mm-hmm mm-hmm
I guess the deals on okay now I need to
unlock what in the world
yeah is not like this is not look pretty
okay oh oh so that's for back up back up
back in the up world memo jail papa the
power pals out scan the person in charge
of it please take over ASAP I assume
everyone knows but since the jails put
power panel is old as hell we're gonna
need to those custom power panel parts
no one makes them anymore there should
be a funeral generally I'm sorry
generator room I got where that there's
only one of those power panel parts in
the generator room the guy that's here
to fix the bell in the clock tower
should have another did a room popped
out okay so even if I did this I
wouldn't do anything like I said I need
to go I'm get those pieces so even if I
do this nothing's gonna happen because I
need power right gotcha
oh okay yeah it's all logs so go back
the other way well I was like oh
friendly I'm not going in there I'm
gonna go in there now I wonder what
would have happened if I went in the
other way fast like I was initially
going to and then got the fuse says or
whatever oh maybe I can only get one and
then oh yeah what have I found them
first and then put power in there then
open the cells would it still just
trigger that cutscene and probably would
have done actually
but it would have been a bit weird
because you would have already unlocked
a cell
oh I don't know who knows target
practice oh there might be some good
stuff in here then Keith the patrol car
seven four three nine bent key no longer
usable but can still open the cars doors
and trunk okay where is it if you got it
have I got it now is it in here so many
questions yeah I think so I probably
just in trees darling
a message from mr. rocket Oh cute howdy
boys and girls it's your pal from
Raccoon City Zoo it's always good to see
you
today I want to talk about something
really important to me you know my
popular mr. raccoon toys well I heard
some bad kids have been using them for
target practice but that makes me real
sad dude little kids wouldn't be that
mean right plus it's super super
dangerous so don't do it
anyway see at the loom mr. raccoon out
I've already been using you for target
practice I'm sorry mr. raccoon
please forgive me I really should go and
save my game hi are you alive oh I don't
like this
I'm just gonna sneak over this way stay
away from you hey no fighting my
southern accent at some point why thank
you
yeah she's like I wouldn't save my game
I keep saying it but I'm just not doing
it mmm it's 4:00 I'll be fine
oh god no not the dogs
Thanks I didn't play wasn't evil sick
then I'm ready to like any of the ones
before that like all the newer ones
because in my eyes there were more just
action and stuff they went like they
weren't horror anymore so I played us an
evil five with my friend because they
have that co-op which is fun it's fun
don't get me wrong but it's not really a
game that I would buy okay I know I
don't want you to break out of that
please don't break out there please
don't break out of that
well the hell is this oh it's a morgue
book rate found dead in jail cell bed by
staff hands and still clenched type
Tooting rigor mortis which should be
coming to an end it's hardly likely that
he died just after lights-out deceased
was a known kleptomaniac incarcerated
multiple times and incredibly he would
steal even while in jail though that was
consistent with his clinical diagnosis
so some things in his hands it's just
what does look for just enhancer nothing
in there
Hey that is new
but they're mighty large let's just
close this we were never here
why are these ones getting stuck
obviously the last one okay so you do I
think you are
did you steal this puppy back
sweet dreams unless it's one of these
maybe that wasn't even him not that's
probably
do you have anything on you ah-ah you
are the one of course of course of
course I mean why would you not actually
oh god oh god I've gotta gotta gotta
gotta go you go there's another one
there's another one there's another one
there's another one I can do I'm out of
here
I'm out of here nope oh Jesus oof it's
okay guys we're okay I think
oh yeah the dogs crank handle slot we
the crank Idol
okay turning around
you're in back yeah the Koran candle
here we go
hmm
wish I could just crawl around in the
vents
not sound fun
oh okay
cool Oh Chinese
oh no that's making dogs
oh hey those bloody things
okay I need all this green air beds
green a dozen green up
[ __ ] a duck yeah you bloody get on your
table yeah
shite
Jesus Christ they're everywhere right
I'm gonna get my shotgun out wait
oh honey what like t-shirts am i right
[Music]
oh really wait [ __ ] wrong way exact oh
my god huh okay I'm safe here and stay
there all right
oh I'm not safe here Jesus I'm safe down
here safe down here
oh my god go down please hi dog spike
okay
let's save and then go kill these dogs
Chinese thing does best for him okay so
the dog should be up here yeah but I'm
just gonna run
come on Ivana bomb right I know what I
know where to go
hey bye
[Music]
great now what
come on still distance again again roll
of film great happy about that
well are you kidding me there's like
nothing in here
huh Oh No
although it's distal oh hello I see huh
is it blocked or something then can add
she go that way
it's literally just out here to go left
yep yep bugger off sweet
yeah and then we can go off says nice
yeah
oh my god we got ourselves a new hat
I wish okay oh oh that feels good
yes oh yeah we need you to different
typing let me turn on the lights
this music is pretty nice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Soulja Boy up in that hoe watch me crank
it watch me roll that's totally how it
goes
incidentally gets darker as soon as you
come out okay now I can explore
everything that I haven't been able to
explain it
just tell me just let me get here please
never come back now
just get under just get under just oh my
god they're [ __ ] everywhere okay huh
must be much nicer but I don't feel like
I want to go this way feel like the only
good that way could I have kept doing no
I can't I can't keep going upstairs that
way anyway so oh well we've got the pink
key now so we can go explore other
places probably
diamond door here we go get into the
linen room oh no that's backed up by the
liquor oh that's the only one as well
looks like any way they can actually go
- okay okay let's go do this oh there's
a combat knife in here somewhere
thank you very much
okay right go be quiet now what's this
yes
I'm just like why I'm just creep in
Oh Oh now I can get the last thing in
that safe if I manage to do this
No
nice yeah
like I sit around there's a sneaky
sneaky sneaky
this is quiet enough do you think
I'm going extremely quietly
okay
so
let's go down here save the game quickly
oh yeah we got a film as well it picked
up o3 ass
locker guides which which Locker jerk
and then it's 300 third floor I know DCM
DC and DC and DC and DC okay
hey you one day you're gonna break
through that DC n what
I think something's coming for me but
I'm doing this slow I'm busy right now
I can't bother with you oh damn it
don't even have it oh my god oh my god
oh my god I think it's the liquor just
go just go
don't even look just go go well when I
do get the Magnum it's gonna be nice
would have a love I'll go for it so I'm
just preparing right now there's another
I think it's it's like time to get oh
hell only on clothes above you there I
don't know how you don't have any blood
on you but you know I guess deny you
have me into the virus maybe your means
up to blood just kind of washes off here
um okay let's try this again
oh god I got I got I got it
ba-ba-ba-ba-bom lovely okay that's this
one choose any others Oh or two or three
and 103
cool and then that's your thing
more space to hold stuff always good
always useful
now I just need to get out of here
without dying I've got the crank and
that's gotta be used somewhere we're
doing is just a prank again mmm I think
I know I'm doing
Oh
if I can get back there oh so annoying
is supposed to be quiet but even
freaking hoping outdoors like triggering
it you make it
[ __ ] this watch this
ha ha go go go go can't go in the safe
room ha ha ha ok safe you miss homie oh
there's a conch handle slot here Oh
perfect
ok that's where I'm going that's where I
need to go that I so does like Imani
that's what these hot guarding that's
what Snape's trying to get sorry hi pot
has been a lot recently
let's get back oh I just go back why
just came the liquors wow they're so
disgusting
No
I'm sorry I put you out of your misery
though you're reaching Oh scandalous
okay what the bloody hell dude do you
just come back every time that's not
cool I just wasted some bullets on you
hey I got two you can keep that one
consider it a parting present where me
I'm going the wrong way
no no I'm going the right way okay
it's crank time this time I need to go I
need to eat I'm hungry
wait
I don't I don't want to waste a bar on
you know so many options what do I do
so many options
up or down up or down up or down
someone playing the piano very badly oh
thank you oh thank you really appreciate
that everybody need to find another
savoring
a large gear I don't know what that's
persecuting
you know what you're not worthy I'm just
gonna go around you
nice oh Jesus whoa whoa no no no I want
that back what that's not yours to keep
Oh ma'am I'm a man I'm going look to
inventory spaces that's luxurious oh
that following me
Oh everybody needs to find a safe room
Oh Oh
what does this dude
let's pull this thing mine to fix this I
guess
let's go
this is the other side cool
was annoyed
don't like that noise
stop what's that noise
oh yeah double headshot yep let's just
check out what's in here you were
trolling me all along
stay down he's still alive
thank you bye yeah you are not now
Gosha some stuff ah that's a savings get
someone lose a key always that the hot
key I was a it's the clover key nice
let's just go put out the fire the fire
just put out the fire and see what's
behind there and then and then I I'll go
nice of snacks
yeah we go
ah
so what does that mean what it's what
does this mean to me that I can go and
search oh god no no oh hell hell hell
hell no oh my god oh my god why do I go
I'm scared
guys guys guys like I'm scared I don't
know what to do
I don't think I can kill him I don't
know what to do you know I don't know
what to do now
not in the safe room
I can hear him walking around outside I
don't wanna go I got let's do a little
Ricky wait up where can I go right let's
be logical here [ __ ] absent DOE and
trying to find something in mind do you
think he's gone
maybe baby's gone
please no gun
how well where am I supposed to go now
what are my options
literally only that oh there's something
here
please still here I'm just gonna give up
I'm scared I'm scared I know he's er
gonna care things around me just just
need to get back
huh what's up noise he's funny isn't he
why it's so intense don't know why the
noise has gotten so intense oh [ __ ] is
right there
I can't see him much it's so light
okay let's just keep going life is hard
no no no I don't have the heart key I
have the clover key no that's even
better because I'm right here they don't
follow me
what's this okay this is the tool that I
need you find right okay that's cool I
already did need that tool oh and you
got the good I need I have to come out
where again well that's it son
guys
guys
I think he's here can you hear that
oh hello
I don't want to go outside
not looking not looking not looking just
keep going [ __ ] freaking here I'm
like walking around this house and it's
absolutely terrifying
okay oh I don't know when to save and
and go make myself some food I can't put
this game down yes watch me crank it
Soulja Boy lovely beautiful
quickly before the zombies come
now new possibilities await
wait I have a bad feeling about this
there's weird music coming from that
door
uh-huh I wish it would show you his
location on the map [ __ ] a duck in the
ass just go I don't know where it's
coming from
just go just about to check my map okay
I can do this good
Oh God don't erase things and check
stuff out oh okay I don't know why I did
that
oh I'm making so much progress with her
plan oh okay this is just tiny about
what I what I've already managed to
achieve so like I don't even need you to
tell me what's due always done that it
looks like I need another one
what this is something here
there's so much of stuffs like everyone
where do I go oh wait did that she pick
up I'm just trying to do everything
quickly like there's an extra sense of
dread because I don't know where that
guy is and every now and then I hear his
footsteps and what the music just goes
crazy and then I go a bit crazy to you
now what is the half
something I need to
uh what what did I even do what did I
even do guys do you know
right and I remember I need to find
another one I know the gearbox is there
back uh-oh I don't like that noise I'm
going I'm leaving the facility well
what's this okay thanks whoa oh thank
you for subscribing oh I don't have
anything
he's literally there run run thank you
for subscribing okay you know what guys
I'm gonna save and go because I need
food but this has been a very pleasant
experience I'm sure we'll play more of
this very soon oh my gosh my heart is
pounding right yes save please ah that's
it we're done we're done we're done here
thank you so much for spending all that
time with me I hope you enjoyed my first
reactions make sure you're following me
on Twitter to see when I'm gonna be
streaming this again next again thank
you so much have a lovely day or evening
and thank you to everyone who is new
year and for the new subscribers for the
new followers um I just got a lot of
things oh my god you just keep going
thank you so much wait what wait I'm
confused guys boys happening yeah I had
so much fun playing that with you night
I hope you guys enjoyed as well oh Jesus
Christ there's so many things so many
things are happening right now
I got raided dude I was wondering what
that was